Russia claims in the past 24 hours it's
killed 250 Ukrainian service members
around donask
there's no doubt many who end up at this
field hospital near buckmut are on the
cusp before The full-scale Invasion we
had 50 to 60 wounded in a nine-month
rotation now sometimes we have more than
that in a day Russian separatists have
controlled part of the Donetsk region
since 2014. all of it now is contested
and ukrainians are fighting in close
proximity with invading forces
for two months Russia has been driving
to capture the eastern city of bakmut
Vladimir zelenski's office called it the
hottest spot on the entire front line
when he visited in December today it is
no less blistering
Ukraine is using infantry and artillery
to hold its ground but the full invasion
is bleeding the country economically as
well it's estimated the country needs up
to 57 billion dollars in financial
support
the U.S treasury secretary Janet Yellen
met with the president in Kiev handling
over the first transfer of 1.25 billion
dollars saying the money will keep
critical Services operating under
extraordinary circumstances attacks on
civilians and civilian infrastructure
have caused many casualties and terrible
sufferings the U.N Human Rights
Commission is set to decide if the
Mandate of the investigative body
examining atrocities in Ukraine should
be extended Russia was suspended from
the unhrc in April but on Thursday the
deputy foreign minister will address the
committee
Crystal commencing Global News London